Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a standard color photo made with a
smartphone.
Hence, it contains only a 2D representation
of the world, and when we look at it, our
brain is able to reconstruct the 3D information
from it.
And I wonder, would it be possible for an
AI to do the same, and go all the way and
create a 3D version of this photo that we
can rotate around?
Well, this new learning-based method promises
exactly that, and if that is at all possible,
even more.
These are big words, so let’s have a look
if it can indeed live up to its promise.
So, first, we take a photograph, and we’ll
find out together in a moment what kind of
phone is needed for this.
Probably an amazing one, right?
For now, this will be the input, and now,
let’s see the 3D photo as an output.
Let’s rotate this around.
And…wow.
This is amazing.
And you know what is even more amazing?
Since pretty much every smartphone is equipped
with a gyroscope, these photos can be rotated
around in harmony with the rotation of our
phones, and wait a second…is this some sort
of misunderstanding, or do I see correctly
that we can even look behind a human if we
wanted to.
That content was not even part of the original
photo!
How does this work?
More on that in a moment.
Also, just imagine putting on a pair of VR
glasses, and looking at a plain 2D photo and
get an experience as if we were really there.
It truly feels like we are living in a science
fiction world.
If we grab our trusty smartphone and use these
images, we can create a timeline full of these
3D photos and marvel at how beautifully we
can scroll such a timeline here.
And now, we have piled up quite a few questions
here.
How is this wizardry possible?
What kind of phone do we need for this?
Do we need a depth sensor?
Maybe even LiDAR?
Let’s look under the hood and find out together.
This is the input.
One colored photograph, that is expected,
and let’s continue…goodness!
Now this is unexpected… the algorithm creates
a depth map by itself.
This depth map tells the algorithm how far
different parts of the image are from the
camera.
Just look at how crisp the outlines are.
My goodness, so good.
Then, with this depth information, it now
has an understanding of what is where in this
image, and creates these layers.
Which is, unfortunately, not much help because,
as you remember, we don’t have any information
on what is behind the person.
No matter, because we can use a technique
that implements image inpainting to fill in
these regions with sensible data.
And now, with this, we can start exploring
these 3D photos.
So…if it created this depth map from the
color information, this means that we don’t
even need a depth sensor for this.
Just a simple, color photograph.
But wait a minute…this means that we can
plug in any photo from any phone or camera
that we or someone else took, at any time…and
I mean at any time, right?
Just imagine taking a black and white photo
of a historic event, colorizing it with a
previous learning-based method, and passing
this color image to this new method, and then,
this happens.
My goodness.
So, all this looks and sounds great, but how
long do we have to wait for such a 3D photo
be generated?
Does my phone battery get completely drained
by the time all this computation is done?
What is your guess?
Please stop the video and leave a comment
with your guess.
I’ll wait.
Alright so is this a battery killer?
Let’s see.
The depth estimation step takes…whoa, a
quarter of a second, inpainting, half a second,
and after a little housekeeping, we find out
that this is not a battery killer at all,
because the whole process is done in approximately
one second.
Holy mother of papers.
I am very excited to see this technique out
there in
the wild as soon as possible.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!